if you entrust me with the presidency  you do not pay  any tax at all because we don't need a  tax code  let me take this moment to say something  we don't say nearly enough  the days of cozying up to the law is  over  i will not let that happen you have my  word  give people school choice with results  available immediately  i hear their voices if you listen you  can hear them too no nearly a century  ago  franklin roosevelt pledged a new deal  too much power  and my fellow americans that is  unforgivable  those are words for our time under  president biden american soldiers  military stay in their homes with  dignity  i accept this nomination thank you and  may god bless you  and may god protect our life liberty and  the pursuit of happiness